[Music]
Boob Mitsuo Nakatani Nakatani Do Co., Ltd. It's been
23 years.
Me Life
Yes, it's also a traditional culture.
Well, when
you're happy, mochi is really attached, isn't it?
There is a rice called glutinous rice that grows well. Well,
I have this glutinous rice to make it.
Well, it arrives firmly and quickly in Japan
.  But in some areas
, it's easy to make mochi. There
is no practice called boo-boo practice
.
Well,
this is only
timing. To get the timing,
I'll do that while calling out. It's a small thing
. It's a
true ball game, so it's a good idea.
Anyone can do it.  Anyone can do it
[Applause]
Yesterday, I made mochi with just g,
so I think that the face when I ate delicious food under the skin with yeah has a unique human face, but
let me see the others.
This is the happiest thing you can do.
[Music]
Maple tempura is a traditional sweet
.
It goes back to 1300 years ago, but
it is only the actual sweets
.
[Music] Hmm [Music]
Name  My name is Setsuko, and
I've been making this maple tempura and
pouring it into it for 50 years
.
[Music]
bouvet The autumn leaves
are a good day.
When you make it
salted all year round
and cut the zip
to give it, it is a tape of letters that you remove the salt
to make a garment and give it with
it.
[Music]
That maple tempura is sometimes raw.
You say you eat it, but it tastes at all. The taste of
maple tempura is that it's
raining because it contains sugar. It's
handmade.
I'll give it to you when it's time to prepare it again. It's been
80 years at home, but I'm
making maple tempura.  It's fun, or
I'm particular about it.
20 degree tempura
There are a lot of customers who
really don't know about depots. Customers come and say it
'sdelicious.
[Music]
2 Ah ah ah
I'm surprised that everyone is seen and listed. Everyone tells me that they haven't sold yet,
but the
color is white and my sister is red and easy to attack. I'm
making strawberry.  Masu
[Music
] Hmm
[Music]
It sells for 15 under the brand name White Jewels. It sells for about 4000
per pack
.
White Jewels basically have a lot of salt in the middle of the night.
But among them, it's
much whiter and bigger
. It's a part that I don't see other people. People other than
me don't make it as a site.
The better the silk is made, the
more
fruit will be left. The red
color will be noticeable, so the probability of becoming a product will
be reduced to about 1/10. It will be a
little expensive part.
It's a market that has increased in total balance in both color, shape and size
. I think the taste is also a wonderful part. It
doesn't have a profound impact on the equipment
, but it's always mysterious and
delicious.
[Music]
Made with white jewels  It's been over 100 years since I started
making white strawberry, and I feel happy that it's fun because I
can often feel that the
taste, scent, and shape that I can't imagine are buried
.
[Music]
No, my goal is  The strawberry tastes like other fruits, it's
sweet, it's delicious, and I
have no choice but to push forward until the customer
tells me that this strawberry is definitely correct.  But
if you look at the making, you can see that
[Music]
Ah ah ah
rar
My name is Hiroshi Sasaki
I entered this road from 18
[Music]
Then, for about 45 years, I specialize only in the wind
I'm moving today
I think it takes at least 10 years to make a real taste
Is it profitable to rub the female sister
? There is a house with too much
bonito flakes, so the reason why I don't accept the bonito that is a colorless and transparent bonito that is mixed with bonito is jr.
Wow de Paris 1
[Music]
Patio is good and it's the best a Even if
you put it in
your mouth, you can put it in your mouth.
The more you use things, the more it
stands out, and the
only thing you have to do is make putty.
The difference in sound is the difference in sound
.
You can see
[Music]
me
Ah ah ah
This is a bonito bonito rim It's made
from that activity
Moonless is
said to be the hardest food in the world, so it
gets so hard
[  Music
] Not included
I'm
making dried bonito or bonito I've been making dried bonito for 30 years
Without hair-
it's not the basis of Japanese food
Katsuobushi, which is called
bonito flakes, is often
used as a so-called topping for young children who eat it as it is on rice, but it is
used in bonito flakes.  After that, you can put the inside of miso in
it. It is
often used for soba and
bonito. The place where dried bonito is produced is
about 90% or more in Kagoshima prefecture, Shizuoka prefecture, but
there are mashed bonito anywhere in the country.
Yama Co., Ltd. says that
this factory
cuts about 70 to 75 tons
of bonito a month and processes about 900 tons of raw materials a year. It takes a long time to make one bonito flakes for half a year.
I did it with a bonito ring
, and then
[music]
It's dried by applying heat
. After drying, I sprayed the bonito bonito on the activity and
lit it for about 4 months or
so, and then 2 deaths.
I think that the bonito bonito craftsman is getting older a. The reason is that
it is mechanized, so
to be honest now.  In that
era, we don't need writers or musicians, so the
number
of magmortars who cut their lives with music like us is steadily decreasing. It
seems that we are the basis of the Japanese food tradition.
I have
a feeling Well, I'm doing my best
, I'm very thinking about going
on.
[Music]
Ah ah
ah ah ah ah
[Music]
voodoo Well,
it's a very
early morning thing that you can't take it.
[Music]
Hmm [Music] voodoo
voodoo Former Fisherman
Boo Boo
[Music]
Boo
Bar [Music] Re Press Genie System words you do Steve Full Nakui Edition 4 s ah andel Service Turu Kitchen
Each n Joyver 9
[Music]  ]
[Music] A
300m square area is always
available at the place where our mozuku is located,
aiming for about 300 from 1 ton to 1 ton
.
[Music]
All Tis Factory
Race Queen Wade Pastor with Day Service
Pencil after Markets this
thousand words place
wh
Boo Boo
[Music]
Say Eating day
50 years 60 years ago, Japanese culture
came in
and I think it's only recently that I've been eating a lot.
I have great potential to spread music all over the world.
Can
tue
nes ocn Change to Aju
So future festival Well 19
Afterimage
It's
technical because it doesn't grow softly and it doesn't grow well, and the other is the environment. No
matter how much technology there
is, it becomes more difficult to make when the environment becomes dirty. Maybe
raising the level of awareness of the environment.
I think it's not against the fact that I'm still receiving a lot of blessings from the sea because it protects the sea
.
This peres ocl application
who
do
[music]
do see
After that, I learned various techniques from my dad.
And I understand the way of thinking
I learned a lot about how to live I have to tell the
strings again
my son 3
luck up
I believe he will take over my business
I don't want to end the
next  I have to connect to the generation properly
[Music]
me
bonnie pink japanese
pou dou
dou Wow
bb 1000 Cab March Ru down
2 down tempo
Lafai Geswords Chain Pole xe
apogee puso mo Winger
voodoo Shower dnase  My teacher is
voodoo
voodoo I'm also conscious of the
Nipashobel quiz.
[music]